el síndrome del intestino irritable y bs
por sus siglas en inglés es una
condición crónica que afecta el
intestino grueso el intestino grueso
también llamado colon incluye el ciego
el colon ascendente el colon transverso
el colon descendente
el colon sigmoide
el recto y el canal anal
la pared muscular del colon se contrae
de manera rítmica llamada peris taxis o
peristaltismo para movilizar el
contenido intestinal hacia el recto
a medida que se contrae el colon absorbe
el agua y los nutrientes de los
alimentos parcialmente digeridos que se
mueven a través de él el material de
desecho llamado heces se almacena en el
recto hasta que es eliminado a través
del ano mediante movimientos
intestinales
cuando padece de y bs las contracciones
de su colon no son normales
en algunos casos las contracciones
provocan que los alimentos pasen
demasiado rápido a través de su colon
como resultado de esto el colon no tiene
el tiempo necesario para absorber la
mayor parte del agua de los alimentos
esta afección produce heces acuosas y
diarrea
en otros casos las contracciones hacen
que los alimentos pasen de manera muy
lenta como resultado el colon absorbe
demasiada agua de los alimentos esta
afección produce heces duras y
estreñimiento
no está claro porque el colon se contrae
de manera normal sin embargo si usted
padece de y bs su colon puede ser más
sensible a ciertos factores tales como
el estrés que parecen no afectar a la
mayoría de las personas otros síntomas
del ibex e incluyen el dolor y malestar
abdominal
hinchazón
gases y retortijones
usted puede manejar los síntomas del ips
por medio de una combinación de cambios
en la dieta manejo del estrés y el uso
de medicamentos
el comer alimentos con alto contenido de
fibra crea heces más blandas y
voluminosas que pueden prevenir las
contracciones spas ticas de colon la
fibra también ayuda a aliviar el
estreñimiento
y las terapias de manejo del estrés
tales como la hipnoterapia y el yoga
pueden ayudarlo a aliviar sus síntomas
su médico le puede recetar medicamentos
para ayudarlo a manejar los síntomas
tales como fármacos contra el
estreñimiento para regular los
movimientos del intestino
antiespasmódicos para minimizar los
espasmos musculares y reducir el dolor o
sedantes y antidepresivos para aliviar
la ansiedad y mejorar su estado de ánimo